next question today is from Roxy Roxy
says have you ever considered a format
change for the show like possibly two
full show interviews I think it would be
great not only have we considered it
we've done it we actually did it about
eight months ago we did - we took to
show separated by a couple of weeks one
was a full hour interview with dave
rubin where we discussed such
interesting topics as classical
liberalism and what that means to him as
well as social welfare programs taxation
healthcare there were a lot of
interesting topics discussed during the
hour we talked about the ideas we talked
about yeah it was really we engaged in a
battle of ideas or at least we engaged
in a battle of ideas within the free bar
rally the battle of ideas or something
like that yeah
I also interviewed Peter Boghossian and
I think it went well
most people tended to like the concept
but not so much the particular guests we
chose so I'm really willing to go back
and try the full hour interview again
some people have increasingly including
on the subreddit been saying David have
you thought about switching over to just
being an interview show like you just do
an hour interview and you don't do any
more of the daily stories I'm willing to
consider anything I like doing
interviews and I like talking about the
Daily News we built the show on
discussing The Daily News so the problem
is we wouldn't lose our entire audience
obviously but we would lose a lot of
people that want to get the daily
updates on the news so the mix is good I
think it's an X ray are there are
interviews if you want them and there's
news I think it would be very risky for
the show to say we are now just an
interview show yeah and I like the
hour-long interviews it's just hard to
find the right topics because the show
goes out on YouTube it also goes out on
broadcast television and radio so
sometimes it's hard to find a guest that
everyone is at least somewhat familiar
with that isn't running into yeah it's
really a guest choice issue but the idea
I floated about eight months ago was
what if one day a week we did instead of
the normal news wrap-up and analysis we
do an hour interview and then we do
three political like our normal
political stories on our bonus show and
it might mix up the format and maybe
also drive member
I don't know that was part of the idea
and we just haven't done it because we
have had a lot of other stuff going on
I'm totally willing I'd be willing to
hear from the audience about it yeah we
got to hear suggestions who should we
interview I mean I think that's a big
question
that's a that's a thing that happened at
the time which was people really did not
agree as to who is worthy of an hour
interview that was a big topic of
contention but Roxy yes I do think about
it and sometimes I just daydream about
what if I did a complete format change
what if this became TechTV or I review
tablets I think a lot of these ideas are
only daydreams because they would
immediately torpedo the show but the our
interview is something that I going back
to